تيك توك الذي نمى بسرعه خارقه في السنوات
الاخيره يحارب اليوم بشكل واضح من امريكا
ودول اوروبيه عديده قررت حظره بطرق عده
لكن لماذا
تيك توك المملوك لشركه بايدن في الصينيه
التي اسسته عام 2012 وصل عدد مستخدمه لنحو
المليار بينهم 150 مليون في امريكا التي
قررت مؤخرا صدره عن اجهزتها الرسميه كما
في بريطانيا ودول اوروبيه اخرى هذه الدول
وعلى راسها الولايات المتحده تتهم بيض
دانس باستخدام بيانات المستخدمين الحساسه
ووضعها بيد الحكومه الصينيه وهو ما تنفيه
الشركه التي قالت انه تم بناء جدران حمايه
للبيانات الامريكيه وتحت اشراف موظفين
امريكيين اما في اسيا وفي اكبر اسواق
التطبيق الهند حضر التيك توك عام 2020
زعمه انه ينقل بيانات المستخدمين سرا الى
خوادم خارجيه او عناصره معاديه للامن
القومي والدفاعي عن الهند كما ان الحكومه
الهنديه اعلنت انها غير راضيه عن كيفيه
تعامل الشركات الصينيه مع المخاوف بشان
جمع البيانات والامن مؤكده ان تيك توك
يشكل تحديدا للسياده السلامه
اكدت ان هناك مفاهيم خاطئه حول التطبيق
الصيني وانه يوفر الحمايه اللازمه لبيانات
المستخدمين مع ذلك ما زالت هناك دول عده
تدرس فرض حظر التطبيق الصيني